وقال وزير العدل في جنوب افريقيا رونالد
لامولا رئيس الفريق القانوني لبلاده في
عقاب انتهاء الجلسه الاولى لمحكمه العدل
الدوليه قال انه يعتقد ان اسرائيل تريد
القضاء على الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه واضاف
رونالد خلال مرافعته ان تدمير حياه
الفلسطينيين لم يبدا في السابع من اكتوبر
بل قبل 76 عاما وقال ان العالم ينتظر ان
تؤدي هذه القضيه الى تغيير الواقع المؤلم
على الارض في قطاع غزه
هل تعتقد شخصيا ان الاسرائيليين يريدون
القضاء على الفلسطينيين في غزه نعم اعتقد
ذلك وزراء اسرائيليون واعضاء برلمان وكذلك
جنرالات عسكريون يصفون الشعب الفلسطيني
بانهم حيوانات بشريه ويريدون محو الشعب
الفلسطيني من غزه ومثل هذه العبارات هي
تحريض على الاباده الجماعيه وبالتالي يجب
مقاومتها ومكافحتها الجمعيه